So how does real change actually
happen in America?
Is it this place where
passionate movements go to die,
kind of like a graveyard of good
intentions?
Or is it more like a garden
where those same ideas actually
plant seeds for the future?
We're going to dive into a
really fascinating debate today
that uses these two powerful
metaphors to get right to the
heart of that question.
OK, so you've probably heard
this phrase before, right?
The graveyard of empires.
It's this idea that huge,
powerful forces, we're talking
the British, the Soviets, even
the US, they all March into
Afghanistan and just get bogged
down.
They get defeated.
The country just waits them out.
It's this incredibly powerful
image of, you know, this deep,
immovable resistance.
And here is where it gets really
interesting.
What if we took that graveyard
idea, but applied it not to
foreign armies, but to America's
own social movements?
The core argument here, and it's
a pretty provocative 1, is that
the country has this weird,
uncanny ability to take in all
that energy from reformers,
exhaust them, and in the end
just neutralize even the most
passionate calls for change from
within.
All right, so how on earth does
that comparison even work?
Let's breakdown what's being
called the graveyard argument.
It draws this direct and
honestly pretty startling
parallel between how Afghanistan
outlasts empires and how
American culture seems to do the
same thing to its own reformers.
And this slide just lays the
whole analogy out perfectly.
Look on the left.
Afghanistan's strategy isn't
about winning a big flashy war.
It's about patience.
It's about absorbing resources,
maybe seeming to comply.
And then as soon as the invaders
energy fades, everything just
snaps back.
Now look at the right The
argument is that American
culture does the exact same
thing to its own movements.
It soaks U all the funding, all
the attention, all the assion
until the movement runs out of
steam and then the old ways just
quietly Cree back in.
So you might be asking, why
would this happen?
Well, the author of this idea
points to two concepts borrowed
straight from physics.
First up is inertia.
You know, like a giant boulder.
A culture just doesn't want to
move.
It resists change.
It takes this enormous non-stop
effort to get it going.
And then there's entropy.
This is just the natural
tendency of things to fall
apart, to go from order back to
chaos.
So once that initial blast of
energy from a movement fades,
entropy kicks in and all those
new systems and rules just start
to decay.
And to make this case, the
source points to a whole bunch
of recent movements, things like
Occupy Wall Street, Black Lives
Matter, all the DEI initiatives,
even things like the trans
rights campaigns or COVID
lockdowns.
The argument is that if you look
closely, they all follow the
same pattern.
This huge explosive surge of
energy at the beginning, then
you get some surface level
compliance from big
institutions.
You know, they change their
logos, they issue statements.
But then as the energy fades,
there's this quiet rollback.
Inertia just takes over again.
OK, but let's be honest, that
whole graveyard idea is pretty
bleak, right?
It's no surprise that it
prompted a really powerful
counter argument with a
completely different and way
more optimistic metaphor.
This one isn't about baring
things, it's about growing them.
And this quote right here, this
really gets to the heart of it.
It just completely flips the
script.
The idea here isn't that America
outlasts movements.
No, it's that America evolves by
outlasting the cynicism, the
belief that change can't happen
in the 1st place.
And that brings us to this
beautiful counter metaphor,
Compost.
The idea is that movements don't
just die and get buried in a
graveyard.
They compost.
They breakdown for sure, but in
doing so they enrich the soil,
the cultural soil, making it
more fertile for the next wave
of reform.
So in this view, what looks like
a failure is actually just
preparation.
And you can see the two ideas
clash directly in this table.
I mean, they're looking at the
exact same phenomena, but coming
to totally opposite conclusions.
For the graveyard view, inertia
is the enemy.
It guarantees failure.
But for the compost view,
inertia is actually a good
thing, kind of like a safety
mechanism for democracy.
Or look at backlash.
The graveyard folks say see
proof it failed.
The compost folks say no way.
That's proof it was having a
real impact.
It's a completely different way
of seeing the world.
OK, So what happens next is
really cool.
The original author, the one who
came up with the graveyard idea,
is faced with this really
compelling, calm host argument.
And they don't just retreat.
Instead, they take that
criticism on board and refine
their idea into something new,
something even more nuanced,
that tries to bring both
perspectives together.
And that leads us to this what
is striking, totally modern
image.
America isn't a graveyard.
It's a mausoleum with Wi-Fi.
Think about it.
A mausoleum is different from a
graveyard, right?
Things aren't just buried and
forgotten.
They're preserved.
They're put on display.
They're admired.
And that with Wi-Fi part.
That's the crucial modern twist.
These ideas are kept digitally
alive, always connected, always
visible.
So what does that mean, exactly?
It means movements aren't
destroyed, but they're not
really composted either.
They're preserved, they get put
behind glass, they're turned
into hashtags, they get
celebrated in corporate mission
statements, and of course, they
get monetized.
All of this creates what the
author calls the illusion of
vitality without life.
It looks alive, you know, but
it's not actually breathing.
This is such a key point.
The system doesn't have to crush
dissent to defeat it anymore.
It just absorbs it.
It metabolizes it.
It takes the raw, powerful
energy of a protest and turns it
into marketable brand content.
So feminism becomes empowerment
branding on AT Shirt.
Environmentalism becomes a new
app to track your carbon
footprint.
The outrage itself is turned
into a product you can sell.
So after all this graveyards,
compost, mausoleums, it brings
us right back to the big central
question at the heart of this
whole debate.
When progress happens, what does
it actually look like?
What does it feel like over the
long haul?
And this might be the best way
to boil it all down.
Is American progress a spiral,
or is it a treadmill?
Are we on a spiral, you know,
constantly moving upward, even
if we circle back and revisit
old fights from a higher level?
Or are we on a treadmill, just
running faster and faster?
The scenery around us is always
updating, but we're not actually
going anywhere.
Let's break that down the
spiral.
That's the optimistic compost
view.
It says, yeah, we might be
fighting the same battles over
and over, but each time we're at
a higher altitude, progress
builds on itself.
It's cumulative.
Then you've got the treadmill.
That's the more skeptical
mausoleum view.
It suggests we're just stuck in
this loop, this constant churn
that just wears us out without
any real forward movement.
Sure, the tech changes, the
slogans get an update, but the
deep down power structures, they
stay exactly the same.
So where does that leave us?
Well, in the end, maybe the
answer isn't about picking a
side graveyard or garden, spiral
or treadmill.
The source material kind of
concludes that the real sign of
a healthy Republic isn't a final
victory for either the optimists
or the cynics.
It's the debate itself.
It's that constant tension, that
pull between those who believe
we're on a spiral and those who
are terrified we're on a
treadmill.
That's the space where a
democracy really lives, or it
argues with itself and where it
keeps breathing.